we've been following breaking news
overnight after a shooting on the las
vegas strip
and they just talked about some of the
closures there metro police say the
victim in this shooting is in the
hospital the shooter though still
on the loose bianca holmen live this
morning on las vegas boulevard with the
latest bianca
good morning john so this is still
developing a very active scene behind me
but
developing as we speak as metro police
search for
a gunman so this is what we know so far
they also want me to really
focus and let you all know that that
this is an isolated incident and there's
no danger to the public so
the investigators say the shooting
happened around 2 20 this morning
there was a fight outside the flamingo
one person was shot and that victim was
rushed to umc
trauma but is expected to survive and as
far as the gunman we don't have a lot of
information we know he took off on foot
and
is still outstanding right now
detectives are on the scene looking at
surveillance video from the flamingo and
other nearby resorts we know there's
lots of cameras everywhere
and they have not yet released a
description or said or where they think
the person ran to in what direction so
again police want to make it clear that
this is an isolated incident but there
is heavy police presence
just because again though folks may
remember last year there were lots of
fights and things happening on the las
vegas strip so
they've increased their patrols here in
this area but again no danger to the
immediate public
to the public in this area or outside of
the las vegas strip we'll continue to
keep you posted once we learn more
information about
the shooter and what happened out here
early this morning back to you guys in
the studio
bianca